Speaker 1: It seems Donald Trump may to
some degree see the writing on the wall
that he may not win the 2024 Republican primary.
We've already speculated, as have a number of
different writers. Is Trump even going to make
it to the Republican primaries? Or will a lack
of support all but force him to bail? Maybe
citing other interests, maybe citing health
issues before a single ballot is even cast in the
2024 Republican primary? Well, there's another
possibility that Trump does run for president, but
not within the Republican primary. And that seems
to be what he is now threatening to do. Trumpist
site encourages Donald to run in a third party,
and he seems down. Former President Donald
Trump. This is from Rolling Stone, who threw
his nightmarish red cat back into the ring and
launched a third bid for the White House. Shared
an article Wednesday that suggested he run as a
third party candidate. Posting untruth, social
censure, the social media platform he started
after being booted from Twitter, Trump promoted
an article from conservative publication American
Greatness Staying True to the site's unofficial
role as a Trump mouthpiece. Dan Gelernter.
GELERNTER Glenn Geller. In turn, that's difficult,
huh? Claimed that the RNC can pretend Trump isn't
loved by the base anymore and that Trump is still
admired and even loved by those who consider
themselves ordinary Americans. Gelernter compared
Trump to the late President Teddy Roosevelt
and suggested the idea of running third party.
Although Gelernter admits that Trump running as a
third party candidate would likely meet a similar
fate to Woodrow Wilson, he declared his allegiance
to the former president. Trump then reposted that,
I guess you could say he retrofitted and media
reports. Trump appears to threaten third party run
to split the Republican Party in half. We want the
Republican Party to destroy itself. Democrats seem
unable to destroy it and in fact sometimes make
very strange decisions that seem to almost prop
it up. But it would be great if the Republican
Party destroyed itself and a third party run by
Donald Trump would splinter the party and it would
absolutely undermine its own chances in future
elections. Now, a key factor to consider when we
think about this is if Trump runs a third party,
what impact does that have on Republican voters?
What would the average Republican voter think?
Because you have these Trump supporters that are
fiercely loyal to an almost cult like degree.
They would certainly follow Trump if he ran as
a third party candidate. That takes votes away
from the Republican Party. And we'll talk in
a moment about why that is so important. That
splits the conservative vote and opens the door
for Democrats, even with a mediocre candidate,
whoever the candidate ends up being, to win
elections. You could also see the Republicans
that are less cult like but are sort of in
the well, we're not. I'm a conservative,
but I'm not a Trump person, but I really don't
like Hillary. I really don't like Biden. So I'm
going to hold my nose and vote for Trump. That
group that is already sort of turned off by
Trump's rhetoric and by Trump's actions. If Trump
runs a third party, that group of Republicans will
absolutely see it as, okay, listen, I held
my nose and I voted for Trump over Hillary,
and I voted for Trump over Biden. But that's
because he was still within the party I support.
Now that Trump is running third party, that's
too much for me. And I'll either stay home or
just vote for the Republican candidate. Even
if I know that it's an inevitability that with
the vote split, the Democrat will win. So it
could also hurt Trump with those reluctant
Trump voters that are really more Republicans
than they are MAGA people. And then there could
be the far reaching consequences for Republicans
more broadly. If you have the vote split in that
way and some people stay home and some vote third
party for Trump, will they be as eager to go out
and vote for Republican candidates for the House
of Representatives? Will these folks who are
kind of disgusted by what might happen within the
Republican Party if Trump runs a third party? Will
they go out and eagerly vote for Republican Senate
candidates? So Trump running third party could be
a delightful disaster for the Republican Party,
not only at the presidential level, but also down
ballot. Now, the math of it for those who may not
know or who. Need a refresher is very simple. The
Trump third party run all but ensures a Democratic
victory in the United States. Much to my dismay,
I don't like the Electoral College system, but
the way you win in the United States is you have
to get a majority of the Electoral College votes.
That means that based on population. Each state
has a different number of votes, or you might
call them points. You need 270 points or votes
to win. And the only way you get those in most
states is by the only way you get any in most
states is by winning the state's popular vote.
If Trump were to run as a third party candidate,
it is likely that he would pull enough votes away
from the Republican candidate that the Republican
candidate would lose, but that he would also
not get enough votes to win himself. Meaning
that a state that might have gone 5545 to
Trump could end up going something like,
you know, just to make it up here, 45% to the
Democrat, 35% to Trump and 30% to the Republican
candidate. Most states do not have a 50% run off
threshold. Georgia does, but not all states do.
And so Trump running third party would all
but seal the deal for the eventual Democratic
nominee. When you split the right wing vote,
you make it easier for Democrats to win, and you
make it easy for Democrats to win with not even a
majority of the vote. The real question becomes,
is Trump dumb enough not to understand the reality
of the math and or is Trump narcissistic enough
to think that this is a good idea?
I hope the answer is yes to both.
And as I've said many times before, as an observer
of politics mean, I'm talking about myself now.
I don't care about the Democratic Party. I'm
not a Democrat. I just vote for whoever I think
is going to do the best job. But I recognize the
dynamics, the party dynamics that exist. I would
love to see the Republican Party damage itself
in exactly this way. Whether Trump will do it,
whether the Republican Party has some failsafe
remains to be seen. Let me know your thoughts.
And folks, make sure as we wrap up 2022 and get
into 2023, make sure you are subscribed to the
YouTube channel. It costs nothing. It affirms what
we do, and it helps us. In YouTube's algorithm,
we're fighting for 2 million YouTube subscribers.
It is not a level reached by too many progressive
YouTube channels. Help us get there. More than
3 million of you regularly watch our clips,
but don't subscribe. Nothing changes for you.
You can still eat whatever food you like.
You can still watch whatever shows you what you
just hit. Subscribe and you get us a little bit
closer to that 2 million threshold. We'll take
a quick break and be back right after this with
the final show of the year. The David Pakman Show
is, of course, a community supported program. We
depend on your support through something we call
the membership program, much to the dismay of many
of our detractors. You can sign up at join Packman
dot com and not only will you get the show every
day with no commercials and either audio or video
forms, you will also get the daily bonus show
explosively produced. After every single day's
podcast you can sign up at, Join Packman Icon and
use the coupon code. 24 starts now to get yourself
a discount. Let's get to phone calls which aren't
really using the phone. They're using discord. You
can find the discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Join the waiting lobby. Let's hear from
some people and remember, you will not be called
on if your name is set to like a nickname or
something like that. We need your name and where
you are calling from. Let's start. Let's see if
this works. We're going to try it. We are starting
today with Kevin from Arlington. Let's see if I
can bring Kevin in. Uh. And here is Kevin. Kevin,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I actually didn't request to
speak, so I'll come up with something.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. Okay. You
had it looked like you wanted to be on today.
Speaker 2: No, I. I didn't like him. But for me.
Speaker 1: The fact that it's so
he could come up with a question.